it's a new week and that means it's time
for new releases and this week we're
getting uncharted for a thief's end
uncharted 4 is set several years after
the events of uncharted 3 drake's
Deception with our hero nathan drake now
retired as a fortune hunter settling
into a life of domestication with his
wife Elena Fisher but you know this
isn't a game about what they're going to
cook for dinner nathan is back and added
again searching for hidden treasure and
you're along for the whole ride reviewer
Mike McCarty said uncharted 4 is a
challenge to the medium in its writing
and its design and its understanding of
what makes games unique uncharted 4 is
something to aspire to it's a shining
example and we'll be talking about it
for years to come it got a 10 out of 10
on gamespot and you're going to want to
grab this game on the 10th doom returns
with a reboot this week but if you're a
fan of the original game be aware that
it might look and feel a little
different as noted by the absence of
doom guide in the players HUD or the
fact that there's no Hut at all for that
matter but you will get some nostalgia
don't you worry weapons such as the
super shotgun and the BFG 9000 will
return and enemies from the original
game like the revenant man Cubist's and
the cyberdemon return as well but they
look a little different and I'm not just
talking about the graphics dooms brutal
campaign will be more than 13 horrifying
hours long and ultra nightmare
difficulty returns will have permadeath
whether you're reliving past moments of
glory or trying a doom game for the
first time you're in for a hell of a
ride try out those sick melee executions
on the 13th
join me 200 years in the future for the
RTS stellaris control ships and research
vessels in a game where combat is more
centered towards the bigger picture you
know preparation and strategy there's
also diplomatic options such as
alliances and trade agreements with
other races the game begins by picking a
species it's ethics and its technologies
and you're not just picking the one that
looks the coolest each species has
unique traits and engineering styles you
explore and colonize space and focus on
diplomacy and governing the whole empire
but it won't be peaceful for long
somebody's going to try and take over
that galaxy and it's up to you to defend
your race from annihilation choose
diplomacy on the 9th developer Moss
gives us a modern revival of an arcade
vertical shoot-'em-up sequel Raiden 5 on
the Xbox one this week the sequel is set
to feature multiple stories as well as
the highest number of stages and weapons
featured in a single Raiden game thus
far you'll be able to trace the trails
of your friends to help others out in
tough areas the battlefield will also
change in real time based on your
actions and those of your friends and
you'll be able to encourage other
players online using the one button
cheer system cheer them on on May
eleventh finally a beloved platformer
from 2010 is making its way to be you
this week it's super meat boy you're a
big wad of meat trying to rescue your
band-aid girlfriend in over 300 well
designed levels that will test your
skills and patience all set to a
wonderful score by Danny baranowski if
you've played this before play it again
and if you haven't well what are you
doing with your life you become the meat
on the 12 remember that release dates
are based on retailer listings and
sometimes they change happy gaming
you